[Music]
the japanese archipelago'
20 years in the future canine saturation
has reached epidemic proportions an
outbreak of dog flu ripped through the
city of Mecca sake
mayor Kobayashi issues emergency orders
calling for a hasty quarantine trash
island becomes an exiled colony the Isle
of Dogs I don't think I can stomach any
more of this garbage nobody's giving up
around here and don't you forget it
ever your Rex your king your Duke your
boss I'm chief we're a pack of scary
indestructible alpha dogs Atari
Kobayashi you heroically hijacked a
junior turboprop XJ 750 and flew it to
the island because of the dog
darn it I've got a crush on you we get
the idea you were looking for your lost
dog spots
does anybody know sparks if he's alive
may very well be living even at this
moment as a captive prisoner somebody is
up to something will you help him the
little pilot why should I
because he's a 12 year old boy dogs love
those
we'll find him wherever he is if he's
alive we'll find your dog it's gonna be
a fight
[Music]
or somebody spoke his language
Wow to the north a long rickety causeway
over noxious sludge marsh leading to a
radioactive landfill polluted by toxic
chemical garbage that's our destination
great get ready to jump
you